este sistema de alerta meteorológica
destaca las zonas más calurosas de
francia el dispositivo creado en 2001
muestra las temperaturas en una escala
que va del verde al rojo de excepción
es algo realmente excepcional y por su
potencial muy grave la gente debe seguir
las medidas de alerta roja
el nivel de alerta fue decidido por
météo france el servicio meteorológico
nacional junto con el ministerio del
interior francés los meteorólogos basan
el nivel en una serie de factores
incluyendo la sequedad del suelo y el
descenso de las temperaturas durante la
noche los niveles de alertas son únicos
para cada departamento pero tienen
consecuencias en todo el país
las empresas tendrán que tomar medidas
para evitar que el personal trabaje
durante las horas de más calor en cuanto
a las localidades habrá centros de
recepción con aire acondicionado y
comprobaremos el nivel de alerta de cada
localidad y quién es más sensible al
calor todo está previsto entonces
expulse es la segunda vez este año que
francia se pone en alerta roja